Maria likes to play baseball.
She plays catch with her brother, Luis.
The baseball coach asks Maria to join the baseball team.
"We play at four o'clock on Tuesdays,"
He says.
"Mom, I really want to play,"
Maria says.
"Can I?"
Maria's mom says yes, and they race home to tell her dad.
Maria wears her baseball mitt to bed the night before her first game.
She gets up to go to school, and her mitt is still on.
At school, Amos gives Maria a note.
The note asks her to come to his birthday party.
"Oh, no! I can't come,"
Maria says.
"I have a big game that day."
"Maybe I could come to your party instead."
Maria asks the coach that night.
"You can miss the game,"
He says.
"But the team will not have a shortstop."
"I should not miss the game,"
Maria says.
"The team needs me."
It is the day of the big game.
All of Maria's family comes to watch.
After the game, Amos comes to give Maria a balloon.
He brings her cake, too!